En fait, je croyais encore une chose
j'étais innocent et c'était moi maintenant
tout comme tu pourrais venir aussi
un pour moi une fois et ensuite je dois le faire
un peu ce que je fais et quand il
Il avait de l'argent et s'il ne l'avait pas, c'était le nôtre
Le collier était également propre en semaine et si c'est le cas
il savait ce que je faisais avec un
Je lui ai dit non
La lune a certainement brillé toute la nuit
C'était certain
fait mais ce n'était pas autorisé à continuer
pas seulement toi-même
allongé oui ou faut-il avoir froid et
être sans coeur
oui, il pourrait
beaucoup
arriver
juste non du tout
Cependant, un jour et le jour qui était
bleu, quelqu'un est arrivé qui n'a pas osé me rencontrer
et il a raccroché son chapeau
le mien
Les choses n'étaient pas nécessaires
plus et quand il n'avait pas d'argent et ça
il n'était pas gentil non plus et son collier
Il n'était pas là dimanche non plus
quand il n'a pas réalisé ce que je faisais
Lady le pousse, je lui ai dit
Non
Je n'ai pas gardé la tête haute
et je ne suis pas à toi
c'est-à-dire toute la nuit
et ça ne pouvait pas être autrement
Je viens de me mettre là-dedans
Je ne pouvais pas faire les chansons
être froid et sans coeur